expire de Laurent Baffie y a pas un gros
mot non par exemple si je prends husky
chien de traîneau
[Rires]
c'est quoi le contraire c'est Yorkshire
30 chien de traîner
[Applaudissements]
j'ai la compile il y a tout là-dedans
hein
ils avaient cartonné
dernière sortie en boîte
gynécologue c'est quoi gynécologue c'est
docteur qui sait lire sur les lèvres
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
petit con qui met les pieds sous la
table et les doigts dans la fille
de pêcheur oh
noli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui pratique le fils fucking sur les
vaches sans être inquiété par la justice
c'est vrai qu'il met le bras on lui dit
pas un mot
ils prennent deux ans
c'est deux points de mesure exactement
qu'est-ce que tu deviens Jean-Marie
alors tu connais la différence entre un
fils fucking et important
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
école sorte de cassoulet on met les
feuilles au devant et les grandes
saucisses derrière
[Applaudissements]
le catéchisme bisexualité optimisation
des orifices ça va
Laurent le catéchisme
je connais sa gueule mais je serais
incapable de m'attendre
où les détenus se masturent devant les
enfants
[Rires]
je vois pas où tu veux en venir
condiment pour tournedos
[Rires]
une propre oui je crois que j'en ai pas
Jean-Marie tu as pas une blague propre
c'est Halloween la porte seule la femme
a dit au mec qu'un grand sourire dit bah
va ouvrir il ouvre la porte et là il
pousse à hurlement ah il jette une
poignée de bonbons et referme la porte
c'était qui dit c'était ta mère
[Applaudissements]
c'est mignon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour sculpteur spécialisés dans
l'autoportrait exemple hier je me suis
fait anglaise aujourd'hui je me suis
fait en bronze moi je vais me faire
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas ça c'est de la sculpture
dans le noir
minuterie ça va
pas une propre
actualité aussi
le militaire russe il s'échappe de la
caserne parce qu'on va l'envoyer au
combat le lendemain déserte quoi et donc
il y a un commando armé qui lui qui lui
court rappelle lui aussi court devant Il
court il court il tourne au coin de la
rue il voit une bonne sœur là il lui dit
ma sœur ma sœur et dit il me court après
il va m'envoyer au front je vais mourir
laissez-moi me cacher sous votre robe ça
fait
le commando il arrive il disait pas vu
un soldat qui courait ici je l'ai vu il
est parti par là
le commando c'est loin il ressort de
dessous la jupe de la bonne sœur dit ma
sœur ma sœur ou ma sauvé la vie sans
vous j’étais mort tu dis Ben et il lui
dit et si je peux me permettre vous avez
de belles jambes et la bonne sœur a dit
bah si tu étais remonté un peu plus haut
tu aurais vu une belle paire de couilles
parce que moi non plus je veux pas y
aller
[Applaudissements]